did you hear that the federal troops are
being removed from portland
uh yeah but i'll believe it when i see
it and also then
uh trump and uh acting dhs secretary
chad wolfe
were like not so fast don't think it's
not like that so kate brown announced it
on twitter
and then they were like not really uh so
it's very nebulous uh nate cohen
who is more informed and well read than
i
just told me this
um the uh quote the big thing is that
the
super shady tactical team from cpb
you know customs and border patrol is
gone they're the ones grabbing people
they're they are always uh fps officers
and marshals there that's normal
they just have extra at the moment so
the phase plan is basically
cpb out uh the others are staying
et cetera um that being said chad wolfe
did say
that uh like he'll keep
stuff there until there's no longer a
threat of violence against the federal
courthouse
and federal properties and in a country
like america that's never going to go
away
um yeah violence i love that building so
much
you know it's a it's not even that sexy
a building um
i mean it gets to just afraid it's gonna
happen to it well i mean at this point
the building
has become a symbol so like yeah do i
think that there's a
probability or possibility that a
significant chunk of the protesters want
to burn it down now
i i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised
people before didn't like the protests
there started
and then the portland police bureau
escalated violence which made people
more want to protest which means much
made them put up a fence which
upset people more and then you know just
kept on
everything that the the local police did
resulted
in not everything they did some things
they didn't
have people show up less but every
proactive thing they did
had more people show up and then once
the feds came in
all that it became like oh that's just
you know that's it like that's uh became
national yeah that became
and then yeah and people who were casual
about the protests
were now listen like they hate trump
they don't like the notion of federal
officers but you know like in a sense
federal troops
you know to be dramatic they don't like
that idea in
their city which they're not they're not
like
diplomats they came ready to [ __ ] people
up oh yeah
yeah a bunch of dweebs coming to
beat us up are they dweebish
i've been out there i've not been
roughed up i'm so
afraid of being roughed up i am so
scared of
any kind of pain i have had the
night the the i got shot in the arm with
something
and it left like a dinky bruise like
nothing photogenic
and i've had so many comrades out there
reporting or
protesting or providing aid who have
been wrecked
and are like uh but yeah um
the you know they're they're they
like they're they're they're they're
spiritually dweebs
sure some of them are gonna be jacked
but like
they yeah exactly they're
you know i mean you know i don't like
the word thugs because it's so
racialized but like
they're they're brutes they're yeah
they're henchmen
you know and yeah
i heard this interview where this dude
was like he was like one of the
border patrol people and he was like i
know a lot of colleagues that
want to crack heads of people that we
disagree with
yeah they disagree with like the people
on facebook
some of them are going to work for the
border patrol
and yeah i mean you know how hateful
they get
yeah facebook so yeah and it's like
you're also like if you're in any kind
of law enforcement
you get kind of indoctrinated into this
death cult sort of where you're like you
can sit there
they condition you to think of yourself
as a predator as a killer
as a an actor of violence so
you're kind of just primed and ready you
want to beat people up and anyone who
tells you
i mean it never feels good when anyone
tells you you're wrong about anything
like that never feels good and now
imagine is people are like
you suck because it was like your job
and you're bad and then of course
they're like
i want to want to crack heads and
you know it's scary because they have no
real discipline they aren't like
it's not like an efficient
[Music]
my mom called me it's not like an
efficient uh
an efficient tool of of of violence it's
it's
which in some ways is good you know it's
not like
it's not like they sent in seal team six
or whatever
yeah but like it's kind of scary that
they just you know they'll pull their
live
they've not used like bullet bullets but
they have
pulled um they have pulled real guns
several times
you know pointed them just
indiscriminately into the crowd they
just been shooting at a lot of people's
heads with like
you know less lethal munitions but i
still crack skulls and
busted on like it's just it's total
chaos and total lack of any kind of
coherent strategy outside of inflicting
pain on people
which yeah you know i think they they
yeah
it's the american tradition that's
that's why people were protesting and
that's why
george floyd died i think it's because
we have this
mentality towards policing i think it's
like
the american job thing like americans
identify as their job
so a policeman has to be the best
policeman they have to like
get the most they have to get the same
energy that a football player gets off a
sack
yeah at their job or like a rapper
so they're competing on that level and i
think
we don't have like culture or
spirituality to fall back on so they're
trying to get everything from their job
and uh yeah i just think that we have a
shallow culture and that is most evident
in our policemen
but there's like a lot of [ __ ] that we
need to change
about what we value and honor in our
society
yeah um it's an angry individualistic
society i mean that is america you know
i mean
it's you know fu i got mine you know so
it's like
yeah it's there isn't really a sense of
greater american community
like these things which is kind of part
of the big initial problem of a lot of
policing
is there's so many problems with
policing i mean like not to give like
anything
as one problem but like most
urban police officers like live in the
burbs they live in the suburbs
and the notion and suburbs have so
little culture
by everyone just drives to to to you
know the red robins etc
just by the g by the architecture of it
you don't like
you know you can kind of know your
neighbors but that's been a big trend in
america not knowing your neighbors so
these
people who live in these atomized
individualized
communities then go to a different
community where they have
no real connection and get to basically
be anonymous
get to have control over people's lives
and get to basically just
enact at whatever kind of brutality they
need to the gnat to fill that weird
american shaped hole in all of our souls
it's weird it's wild it's it's a bummer
not good
don't recommend zero yeah
yeah so i mean what's the alternative we
have to
produce a nouveau culture because we
can't go back to
primitive tribalism yeah i mean there's
are there smarter people than i who have
um who have come up with the exact
so i mean with suggestions for the
solution i
have not really i don't have a solution
that i love personally
for because we the big problem of course
is
like police culture since
forever but really since like the reagan
era
has like skyrocketed in terms of its
weird cultish behavior
like i mean i'm never it's not like
there was ever a golden arrow when
police weren't racist
when police weren't actively used to
you know enslave or re-enslave black
americans like it's
it's it's not like that i mean police
have always been
in some form or the other a tool of of
the oppressive capitalist racist state
but
you know ever since i don't know you
know the reagan revolution
cops have gotten a lot more into the
brand of like
being blue and thin blue line and blue
lives matter and all that jazz
um so it's it's it it's
it seems like you kind of would have to
start from scratch
um yeah and that's i feel like
reagan it was like uh like a local comp
yeah walk the beat and then you got into
like
living in the suburbs and commuting to
your police job downtown
and i heard that like 18 of portland
cops live in portland
yeah it's an absurd yeah it's so few mo
yeah
so few portland cops live in portland
and then in that case you have less
reason to be worried
about people and you're like in your
community hating on you because like if
you
if you live in the community and you
kill someone in the community
you or beat someone up in the community
you gotta have to deal with
like people not liking you
right and that's the best the greatest
governing tool is the uh among humans
is inter-social pressure um and that's
kind of
i mean america has done a great job of
destroying that and all of our
communities is
so rare to know your neighbors even if
you live in a city it's it's
it's a bummer um i mean i have a big
fear that like
given how radicalized cops have been we
can't just abolish the police like that
because then the police will still exist
and then you're like where do they go
you look at like the best historical uh
how do you say uh analog for abolishing
the police is
a rock after we got rid of the bath
party
the bath party of course wasn't like a
religious group
but it was a uh uh you know kind of like
a
an oppressive political semi-death cult
all under you know
saddam's power so you get rid of all
those bath guys
you know okay your party's done saddam's
gone your government structure is gone
where do they go
a lot of them went to form isis you know
even though isis is you know
people talk about isis as of course like
a religious organization but really it's
kind of like a violent make worth
work organization it's something i'm
afraid
you're afraid that uh police are gonna
form like a white isis
yeah yeah isis um uh no it's something
like i mean because what are they gonna
do like
if you're trained to like think the
entire world is against you
and that like these these antifa and
black lives matter
thugs are like terrorizing the world and
i'm the only one
i'm the thin blue line defending like
our pres you know like what are they
gonna do you know
are they gonna go become a barista like
gonna work at target like can you
imagine like a cop
like working customer service like
the ego yeah can you imagine like just
like deal like an uber
like a copying an uber driver i know
there are copyright like
all these things that like yeah what are
they gonna do
like if i was if i was like a weird
nationalist
organization leader or a like a white
nationalist organization leader
or like a whatever a non-white
nationalist one
like if i was a weird sovereignty group
yeah any of that weird stuff or if i ran
a cult
like grabbing cops if they got
you know if the if the police
disappeared grabbing cops to join my
cause would be
right on top of my list it's you know
they they yeah so so you know
i don't know i don't know i got to take
care of them yeah gotta give them
something to do
i don't know like yeah yeah have them so
yeah i mean when people hear about the
portland protests
like the right people who are against it
or just like moderates will be like why
do they have to
why don't they have to try to break into
the federal courthouse where they have
to
try to start a fire what are they doing
that for
like what do you say to that i mean
there isn't a defined leadership of the
of the portland protests and that's kind
of by design but kind of by
the universality of the oppression and
the pain
because like as the protest has been
happening
the cops and the feds have escalated so
much they've radicalized
thousands of portlandians who weren't
normally radicalized
so like there's a lot of pain and anger
that they've caused
so like all it takes is one person to
start a fire
all it takes is one person to try to get
into the federal courthouse like
if they don't there's a huge array
of different ideologies at the portland
protest because of a huge array of
people that have been brutalized or know
people had been brutalized
by the portland police by police in
other cities
by uh you know by the feds so
when people say like oh like why can't
they just
be more respectable it's like
you can't control that you can't control
a mass movement um
and like it's it's
it's a statement i've talked to moms out
there you know the the wall of moms
which
you know is its own thing um stuff's
been happening with them this morning or
at least our online organization or
whatever but like i talked to like some
like
middle-aged suburban moms who uh
what's it called um who uh
who are like yeah i wanna like tear [ __ ]
down because they're mad
um you know people don't like to do
mass property destruction unless there's
like a
a a spiritual reason kind of a
ritualized reason
the the the fence the initial portland
sacred fence
that was erected between the protesters
and the justice center became a
flashpoint that people wanted to tear
down
because it was like a symbol of like the
state ignoring the people
the justice center has become a
flashpoint because that's where all the
the feds and like a lot of the ppv are
like stationed
so it's so people want to start fires
there because
they want to like express their rage at
that location at that symbolic location
and also a large chunk of the people
there want to
instigate uh some kind of state violence
because the state violence is so extreme
and unnecessary
that every time they do it it shows that
like
that the state is out of control like
you throw i've now
i've mostly i've just been documenting
and chanting uh but you if
if someone throws a water bottle at a
cop like that's half full
do they deserve to get riddled with
pepper pellets like do they deserve to
get a
tear gas canister in their head i'd say
no
um and people see that and go wow
that sucks i'll be out there tomorrow
and then they get a tear gas canister in
their chest
and they go out that hurt and i feared
for my life
i'm now kind of addicted to the black
lives matter protest i'm gonna go out
i'm gonna
tell my friends to come out so it's it's
kind of like
it you know peaceful protests
like uh the protests i've been out have
always been
peaceful in a lot of ways they've always
they've always mostly been peaceful
they've been
that's a term that kind of means nothing
because but like the feds and the cops
are the instigators
and i don't know so it's like if people
don't want
people don't want there to be violence
or damn property destruction there they
should really talk to the feds and the
cops and get them to stop doing it
that's
that's my take yeah i mean if you
uh shoot tear gas
at a crowd of people and rubber bullets
and stuff
then you should be expected to have uh
violence be met back yeah and it's it's
not just like a one-time thing
it's like there was a back and forth
going on yeah
and uh just because the feds are gone i
mean portland police were pretty
uh violent yeah before the feds i mean
they were yeah
50 days of the portland police being
violent like
and there were some ways they were more
violent than the feds so you think the
feds on the whole have been more violent
but the portland police
were more inclined to chase the
protesters through town because they
knew
that i was in a car a crowd where the
portland police drove into it
they didn't hit anybody luckily everyone
was able to get out of the way but
if people didn't get out of the way they
would have been hit like
the it's all yeah the portland police
like it's yeah and just for the record
the feds are not gone we do not know if
they are actually going to be gone it's
so
confusing uh and i don't like
how everything was posted you know like
kate brown tweeted that they're leaving
and now it seems like
they either and then chad wolfe said
they're not leaving and who knows what's
happening we'll have to wait and see
it's tonight's gonna be wild out there
um or i mean go on
yeah i mean if if they leave say they
leave then that's
that's pretty good good thing that
happens and he shows how ridiculous
trump was he just sent them in with no
plan and was like uh
i don't know what it's like iraq yep
george bush said
it's like every it's kind of funny if
they leave it
it's like every single a modern american
use of like military force um
we just it's it's no yeah vietnam
uh iraq afghanistan
yep like just send them in and then and
then we lose
after we cause a lot of pain and
destruction and then we we
leave or we stay forever um
and like just we always we love to like
i've been like thinking it's like it's
so weird that like
because we didn't win in korea either
like
like the amount of times america like
has
won like a federal any kind of use of
federal force is so small
like how even when we like did our silly
war against granada
you know we still like lost a boat
like of people bought because we flipped
it over because our equipment is
so bad um it's weird um
it's it's it's wild like even um
yeah like it's good i think it's on the
whole if the feds leave it's good
because the feds are are a different
type of brutal and they're using like
expired tear gas and for people that
have uteruses it's really messing them
up um
but there is a
thing to be said that the federal troops
brought in a lot more or the federal
forces i don't know i mean troops are
the vague concept
but the federal forces brought in a lot
more
national attention and a lot more
casual protesters who have now become
like
you know now become like black block
antifa
black liberation people you know like
that dude what's his name chris david
the
the the the giant like 50 year old
marine dude
not very navy guy yeah like he would he
wasn't out there
except for like once the feds were out
there and then they
responded by wimpily trying to beat you
know beat him up
um yeah it was great for the movement he
was
it you know like
uh like stuff like that like so
so there's like from a propaganda
perspective for the people who are
supporting
you know black liberation especially in
portland which is such a white city um
the feds the feds
there's an argument to be made that the
feds were a good
galvanizing point that you know and it's
really
the question of do you value like
what's your strategy on like trading
lives like
is is is a bunch of people getting
brutalized
worth it for the greater good and that's
so so the question are you
utilitarian or not and um
yeah i'm not saying i'm one way or the
other because like
i just like i i just try to go out there
and document um
i have a very small platform but i have
a platform that at least i know have
some people that like aren't seeing
other stuff there are so many better
people reporting
than me when i go out there but uh you
know
anyway it's it's trying to be as
objective as i can and i don't really
even know
like how i fully feel because it was
awesome seeing
seeing when the federal troops came in
seeing the amount of people
who had previously not been out there
that
seeing them come in and be like oh cool
and hopefully if the federal troops
leave those people
still realize that the portland police
bureau brutalized portland
for you know almost two months you know
prior to
trump's stormtrooper is coming in and
you know who knows you know yeah
hopefully they stick
yeah yeah um like
so i think like trump did it so that he
could
be the law and order like show hey look
do you want
the left to win because you're just
going to do this
and then knock on the left and antifa's
they just want to burn everything down
yeah and they don't have a replacement
strategy
but i i don't like that argument because
it's like
just because we notice something is
wrong doesn't mean that
we have to have like a complete
different
government structure and yeah to replace
it to
tell you that hey maybe we shouldn't be
committing violence
like in a very robotic way just as a
habit
so yeah and and also the whole argument
that
antifa and black lives matter don't have
well first off black lives matter is a
real movement and antifa is is
a very vague philosophy um
so uh like it's one of those things but
like part of this is
how the national media covers it the
national media is bad
um generally like they've done some good
stuff but like
they've been bad and how they cover it
because like teresa rayford's
with organization other people i don't
want to like ignore the other people
work but like don't shoot pdx has a lot
of policy
propositions that are really good and
there are a lot of people who've been
working
like night and day coming up with good
ways to reallocate the funds that go
into
every police bureau across the nation
and there is like there is good plans
there is like how to reinvest
i mean so much money that goes to police
would actually prevent crime if we were
housing people so that they
weren't driven to like severe mental
health crisis
by being forced to live on the street
like
there is like there is there are like
clear plans but of course
the media covers it and they're like
look at these these vegan
hippies with their hacky sacks it's the
same thing with occupy wall street
occupy wall street did have
clear policy proposals but the media
both the right wing and like the center
media and
jon stewart people like that all like
really look at these kids and their
stoner jackets like they had policy off
plans just no one
acknowledged them black lives matter and
all that group that's i'm ranting i
drink a lot of coffee today and i'm
yeah um so yeah so i see what you're i
don't know it is frustrating because
like first off protesting something
that's wrong
is is cool and you shouldn't have to
like be like here's my academic treaty
that's
20 pages long about like or treaties
about how
like here's what we should do with
policing in america you should just say
it's wrong that black people get
systemically
brutalized and murdered and indigenous
people get brutalized and murdered and
in general a lot of people of color get
brutalized and murdered
you can say that's wrong and then go out
and fight there hell you know what a lot
of white people
get killed also by the cops and you know
white people should also be out there
protesting that because
cops like you know cops are racist
definitely but they're also
like indiscriminate murderers and in
like it's just
when things are wrong it's good to
protest things that are wrong and you
don't need to be an expert about it um
yeah yeah i mean they have this habit
they they know how to treat protesters
so that nothing happens
they did this for the vietnam protest
yeah i mean
the right you will use every dirty trick
in the book to win the culture war
because they know they can't compete
logically so they just use their power
like nixon and reagan and just
shove their ideas down their throats
yeah
yeah that's ain't that the truth um
you know and i mean of course of course
george w bush i mean
one of the most de-radicalizing elements
of my life was seeing how
impotent the anti-iraq war protests were
you know like like all
all that energy and momentum and then
we'd still committed a genocide and
we still have destroyed an entire region
of the world
and we're still there yeah yeah for
weapons of mass destruction yeah
apparently
yeah and like even like even like
yeah it's it's it's ridiculous what we
did i mean we barely even got any
control of the oil because we
destabilized the reason region so much
that we couldn't
we're still like struggling to like
get like the wealth that we were trying
to loot and it's
it's just like so aimless it's not even
like evil
it's just incompetent it's like they
can't help themselves they're like a dog
that chases its tail they got to go
attack other countries it's capitalism
baby because like
because like that's the thing is that we
have these all these defense contractors
that's like the only thing the american
like
economy is producing so we just have to
keep on justifying these like
super planes and helicopters that
explode when they like
fly above 30 feet and like we have to
just keep on making all this like
junk and yeah and another and then the
cops buy it and the federal
officers buy it and they're using it
against like the people of portland
right now and they're planning on using
it in albuquerque and chicago they're
using it in
new york they're using it and i mean
they're using it in chicago already i
believe but yeah like
they they got to justify their purchases
um and they keep on making them um and
that's the only thing america seems to
be made in america right now
uh is just weapons used to brutalize
and destroy lives um
it's a bummer yep
and we have we have a 40 trillion dollar
hammer budget
yeah i i i agree to some extent but i
disagree mostly because
world war ii definitely was a
significant way to get out of the great
depression
um but like of course the new deal was
hugely important for that too
we gave a bunch of people jobs so they
wouldn't create a mass
[Music]
bolshevik revolution in america like
the entire national not the entire
national park service but a huge
majority of the national parks in
america
were built and maintained
and like monuments was crafted there by
all these people who had been who had
lost their entire lives
during the great depression and we were
giving people jobs and then of course
when world war ii happened
we actually like turned around and were
like okay we have these decent paying
jobs for men and women
to like build stuff and that contributed
to
the new deal bump that had already
happened but of course
like world war ii was was very different
than like
i don't know when like lockheed martin's
making like
the you know an apache helicop like
there isn't actually like an enemy
like nazi germany and like and like uh
you know at the uh what was the what was
the
emperor of japan like and of course the
italians but like
recently wasn't that yeah
yeah um they're the they're the third
wheel on the
the the japan germany date and then
they're like i'm a hero too
uh um it's a me mussolini um
sorry for my anti-italian racism
um uh um yeah yeah yeah um
yep yeah
um irani iran so the least
the least uh the least brown middle
easterners um
yeah um but uh yeah um
i gotta get my and of course i've been
living in portland for 12 years which uh
you know gets you a nice pastiness i've
been taking advantage of the
summer to to bulk up on my tan um
uh no um yeah
uh what was i gonna yeah so um yeah i
mean world war ii definitely helped but
like
our the economy changed so much i mean
wages back then were so much better rep
representatively like jobs were better
there were real unions
like yeah
so it's like now like even if we got
invaded by like
the independence day aliens or something
like we couldn't like
we wouldn't have the same work
economy bump uh because
you know i don't care it's it's so bleak
um yeah so so like these
you know military contractors of course
even though we produce a lot of the
equipment it doesn't
benefit us you know i don't know
what's the quote it's easier to imagine
the end of the world than the end of
capitalism
um i don't know depending on my mood
sometimes i'm super optimistic um and
sometimes i'm very bleak
uh i mean of course the the
the defeat of um of brother bernard
sanders
was a a pretty bleak wake-up call
um to what you know the american people
genuinely want because he was still a
capitalist he was you know a capitalist
it just had minor social reforms
um uh like he was saying what if
instead of what if we use some of this
power of capitalism to help your life
and the voters were like uh no uh
we don't want to make our own lives
better uh in spleek
um so what do you imagine after
capitalism is like
i don't know full-on
i don't know apocalypse the
totalitarianism i don't know like i'm
i'm not in a good mood about it today
when you're yeah
oh we're not getting star trek we're not
getting star trek
um i would love i wish
i just feel like like look at like
we're on the same age our entire lives
we've been hearing about
climate change and how it's destroying
the world and we've been seeing it
happen more and more and nothing has
changed
um where nothing has stopped so like
what's gonna happen when like bangladesh
becomes unlivable because sea levels
have risen
what's going to happen when like qatar
and
bahrain and kuwait and saudi arabia and
yemen and oman become unlivable because
of the heat we're going to have these
migration movements
that are going to be these massive
amounts of people all over
like from all over the world primarily
from the the global south
from these from the brown the black and
brown nations
and then it scares me to think that like
and already you get these white
supremacists in europe and america who
are talking about this and they're like
we have to protect our countries you
know and our heritage from the countries
that they've looted and destroyed
um and it's gonna have i don't know i
get really bleak
i get uh so let me be optimistic i think
i think the the police state will come
down
and we will do restorative social
justice
socialist justice for the world we will
we will we will we will stop global
warming
and we will that's my hope
i'm just going to try to i'm just going
to choose to believe
yeah i can't even finish that yeah um
yeah oh i don't know i don't know
i don't know i miss comedy um i miss
doing like pot
like oh it's so bleak
yeah it was you know and that
i mean i don't know i get worried about
the the idea of population control um we
no
no because we have enough p enough
resources to feed everyone
like to have everyone on the planet be
fat and rich basically
i'm not rich because like the relative
rich is a relative concept but like
i get worried about that because that
just who's that's going to affect it's
going to affect like
indian minorities and chinese minorities
and like in china and india it's going
to like the bourgeois
it's not like we're going to be like hey
england work on your population
control yeah i think it works i don't
know maybe ai will help
but like i don't trust i don't trust the
bezos's i don't trust the epstein's
and the you know the the the the elon
musk's
you know and all you know i mean the
koch brothers
like they're all like the people that
control the world
um i mean they're not going down without
a fight and they already have won
so so if if ai gets made
hopefully somehow it's moral but i can't
imagine that like the same
people who like you know
like are actively destroying earth
are like gonna make a they're the ones
that are gonna control what the ai
thinks i don't know
i guess i guess i'm a communist i
i don't think about my political
ideology as much as i
i mean i think about the ideology i have
but i don't think about the label for it
as much
you know i'm definitely moving towards
anarchism but not like anarchism like
there isn't any society you know get rid
of it
but more like you know communist
anarchism
where it's where it's you know smaller
intercommunal spaces that protect each
other and regulate each other
um basically you know not of course
tribalism
or whatever because that is kind of
destroyed and hopeless in a
global world but i mean that's
the only way to like the only way to
like hold any of us accountable
uh any or any of the people with power
accountable is if power is lessened and
diffused throughout all communities
and you know yeah so
which you know hopefully maybe maybe
things will get so bad
you know who knows i mean we're in this
time of covid where it's like
maybe maybe society will cl crumble so
much that all the the
the gen zers and the next gens will
become full-on anarchists
pull down the state take care of each
other
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i mean covet is the great
uh is the great what's it called um
uh yeah it's the great radicalizer
because
it is showing us that like first having
your healthcare tied to your employment
is bad
it shows us that there isn't really any
protections i've been on
i've been waiting for my unemployment to
get processed for over three months
um and it just hasn't been processed
which uh
i have an okay living scenario that has
resulted in me being able to survive
and uh but a lot i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well honestly there's what's it
called here let me see let me see if i
can show you this um
so uh we have uh our organ unemployment
number that you that you're supposed to
call and here's the number
i'm calling it right now i'm putting on
speaker unemployment
let's see does it ring not ringing yet
but our yeah our systems are just so bad
there it is
there it is i don't know if you hear
that yep it's it's always busy
and it just stays like that forever and
you can't leave a message
they don't put you on hold you just have
to do it over and over i've never i've
gotten through with some like nefarious
tactics
but then like those avenues got closed
you know the moment people
exploit them so it's yeah it's people
are realizing
how little safety net there is
for um for anyone that isn't
anyone at all it pretty much that isn't
super super super powerful
um so
[Music]
yeah thank god i stole my food stamps um
yeah um yeah
um so i was out for
about about 20
days and nights at various protests and
rallies i used to go to the marches but
i eventually felt that my energy was
better used for
getting chased around by the cops
downtown at night
um and but other people have been
out so much more than i am i every now
and again i see someone say like oh
chrishodomy was out every night no no no
no no no i i'm a coward i and i i would
need to take time off after my first
gasting i took 13 days off
and i had an excuse for every night i
took off but i was like
but deep down it was because i don't i
didn't want to be out there
um so uh
so where are they going oh yeah so the
moo yeah so basically like
there are people in town that suck who
have like bad ideology about it or like
who don't support
uh the protest movement but the general
mood in the town
is people who can protest
want to go out to protest and people who
can't are fracked with guilt
that they can't and are donating money
to awesome causes
donating supplies to awesome causes
offering rides to people that need to be
saved
like posting everyone is of people
becoming citizen journalists
a lot of people are i mean like there
are so many people i mean like
ben tier is doing great work out there
and of course like chuck woodstock and
corey alia
and i write okay and sergio almost
and and suzette smith and i'm forgetting
some names oh
uh lindsay smith i mean there's so many
great people out there
doing amazing work um endless uh people
covering what's happening like
people are all cause i'm on quarantine
right now because my parents are coming
up here in a week
and if i give them covet i will feel
very very guilty for killing my old
parents
um so i don't want to be in a big crowd
of people who are like
coughing up air because they've been
gassed with weird
chemicals in 2001 like i don't want any
of that but the mood important it is
like
people are pissed at their feds here
people are pissed that the portland
police
are working with them and that the
portland police
in general have been so brutal people
are very much in support
the movement isn't dying it just seems
to get bigger and bigger and bigger
it doesn't lose focus of black people
and that is a thing that the national
media has been saying which i would say
is almost a bold bold-faced lie
is the national media is trying to draw
attention away
from black people and from black
liberation and from black lives matter
but every time i've been out at the
marches
they still say george george floyd's
name they still say brianna taylor
they say quantities hayes they say i
mean like they say every
everyone's name down to emmett till you
know like
they're still that they're still people
are still protesting for that
the people who are given space and time
to speak
are black leaders and black people in
general uh
the protests still chant black lives
matter they still chant the names
uh black people who like make statements
just even in a crowd
are given space that they deserve and
respect and all that like the movement
like people are still protesting for
black lives the people in the protests
and the marches have not lost track of
that
uh the media likes to make it seem like
it's a bunch of white anarchists
but the crowds are pretty damn diverse i
mean you've been to portland before you
know it's like
like it's not that hard to be diverse
and poor like it's not that hard to make
a diverse crowd in portland
it's like you know it's
yeah yeah
it works to um uh
it works to like yeah i mean america
needs black oppression into it
america needs to oppress black people to
like function as
is it just it's built into our like
structure
so like these you know i mean i mean
it's just we you need a permanent
underclass to like
um you know uh to
to like be labor our economy was built
on on slave labor for the longest time
when that got taken away immediately
especially jim crow which was pretty
much the same thing
and then of course you know i mean
prison labor
yeah it it needs to have you can't just
have extended exponential growth
without some people like it's at the
bottom
um and when you have racialized
it's easier to get people to support it
you know if it's just if it's all
if everyone sees themselves as equally
on the bottom rung
solidarity forms but one of you know the
greatest
achievements of the american empire has
been convincing
like poor white people that they're not
like
they shouldn't have solidarity with poor
black people and
you know they should um you know
yep yep um so yeah so of course you know
you're gonna see like the national media
even like the liberal media
like even them they're gonna be like
they're not gonna
they're i mean with the washington post
is owned by jeff bezos
jeff bezos needs poor people to work in
his amazon warehouses
you know like they're not gonna
like they're not i it's not so much that
they actively are going to try to
delegitimize the
protest movements it's more that you
hire people
who actively disengage who aren't
engaged with
that class level you know you see like
new york times like they just wrote an
article
this is just a weird example but they
wrote an article about like
it was titled like why i live in new
york when you can live anywhere
it was about people moving out of new
york during
[Music]
knockout it's about people who left new
york
um after living in uh
after the coronavirus because why would
you live in new york if you
uh if you um how do you say if you
aren't getting the perks of new york if
you can't like go to like new york bars
and see new york comedy and new york art
and go to broadway all that
otherwise you're just paying way too
much but the article was about this like
these two like employ an employed
married couple with like a
shared like yearly income of like 0.9
million dollars
who moved to like ohio to like have more
money
and it's like no i know so many people
in new york who have had to move out of
new york and live back
with their family because their jobs
died in new york and they can't afford
like
you know 15 1500
dollar rent for a harry potter closet
you know like
like it's and but the new york times
they wrote that
like that because the people that you
they hire
are people with a class interest and
class awareness
of some people making almost a million
dollars a year
and so it's like so
yeah so you're going to see a lot of
people yeah so it's just down now it's
one of those things
you're going to see a lot of people say
that's one like oh the protests have
lost focus they're no longer fighting
for black people
every time i've been out there the signs
are still for black people they're no
joke
they're very few joke ironic signs
they're not they're still focused on
black people every you know
they're focused they they they still
bring up brianna taylor they still bring
up george floyd
the people that you know started this
current iteration of black lives matter
movement i mean the the executions that
started it like
they still do all that and
it's good that's optimistic i i mean i
do think i got depressed earlier of
course in this call
thinking about the bleak state of the
world
but i don't know i think that we've
reached a point where
at least the current structure of police
in america can't go back to
normal um too many people have seen the
horrible
behavior of the police and also too many
people have been like
oh that does seem like reasonable
requests to the police
and then watched as the police responded
with like a violent tantrum
you know so yeah i don't know i i've
been rambling but i like talk i
appreciate getting into
to to to purge some of my hot takes or
my lukewarm takes
it's wild i've been here 12 years and
portland has never been as relevant as
it is today
yeah yeah you guys you guys had us
at northwest a lot of people get
bundled up during the winter you know
we're trapped inside when it's wet and
cold and then we
pop explode out um
there are all these white supremacists
around to agitate stuff
you know it's it's it's these like white
supremacists
surrounding these like small areas of
progressivism so it
creates a lot of tension um
yeah i mean y'all y'all up in in in
seattle need to step up your game you
usually are better than us
but uh and you were i mean when you had
the chazz
and then when you you just burned down
that uh juvenile detention
that was awesome or i don't know
mandatorializing it would
i think it's cool that uh they burnt
down
a thing that was gonna jail
kids yeah um that was
like so so but you all need to step it
up um your
your cops are different than ours
because we have
like vampire cops they only do brutality
at night
i saw yours were just like day walkers
which is
yeah um yeah so
yeah yeah
yeah well cop unions are
the strongest unions in america which is
hilarious because cops
were and one of the things that cops did
in their earliest history was
bust up unions so i guess you know if
you kill enough unions you gain their
power
um
yeah exactly you eat the souls of a
union
um
um you know like
no protest movement that's ever been
successful hasn't had something that the
state has deemed
violent because like history has
has uh softened
or martin luther king uh but people were
calling his protests of ireland all the
time
um there isn't you look you want to look
for like
a non-violent protest you look at like
the women's march or you look at
the march for sanity do you remember
remember the rally to restore sanity
oh it was john it was john stewart and
stephen colbert making
fun of and they were like we've got
these enviro we've got these white
supremacists on the right
and environmentalists on the left and
they're both equally
not sane it's like um
it's both you know it's whatever um
but uh it's and i i
really i i think the women's march was
really awesome and
good and i like but
it didn't do anything um because there
wasn't any
the state understood that they if if
they had shot one white woman there you
know
i mean can you imagine can you imagine
the trump and
trump would have been pulled out of uh
out of the white house and executed if
like they had killed someone at the
women's march you know what i mean like
like that would have gone insane and
that's kind of the smart thing but like
peaceful movements are the movement here
is i would argue peaceful it's not like
no one's bringing guns they're bringing
shields lacrosse sticks hockey sticks
they're
all the way the weapons people are
bringing fireworks
then they're not using anything that's
dangerous
on any real level against the the
guns and explosions and batons being
used like
so but like
a peaceful thing that does no prop that
doesn't inconvenience capital
never is going to get the p like
never going to get a pressure like
people are just going to wait for it to
burn out but like
for yeah every day that go on
exactly um and we want yeah like so
i think some protesting is good and of
course you know sometimes it's bad but
you know like
like you get what you want when the
local
chamber of commerce is like we got to
stop these protests because like no
one's going to the mall
anymore yeah like you got you got to
make it's direct action
i don't support i don't support violence
but i support direct action
like um
it and it's it's that and direct action
is called violence by the state in it
you know so it's it's
it's all violence um it's the whole why
are you resisting i feared for my life
everything against the state is
considered a violent movement because
it's because because it's a threat
and they got to delegitimize it so yeah
i don't support
[Music]
one trillion percent yeah like it's
the portland police and i mean the
national police in general
really you know i mean every time anyone
has asked them to be accountable have
been like aggressive
and violent and
the more you do that the more people
were pissed off like who has like good
experiences with cops
even like if they're white like like
it's so weird that like if they had just
done
some minor reforms
like they probably wouldn't be in this
boondoggle where at this point like i
can't imagine that the portland police
bureau survives
like i don't know how long they can go
on like this
at least and then that would create a
national web because like
people in atlanta will be like wait
portland got rid of their current police
structure why aren't we doing
that minneapolis would be like hey they
said they were going to defund them but
they stopped doing that let's get rid of
that like
because let's say these protests calm
down
how long until another another person of
color is executed in the streets
by the cops or killed in their bed or
you know
pair paralyzed or what you know how long
until that happens and there'll be
another protest
and everyone who is radicalized from
this protest
will be out there maybe not everyone
some people will have a job some people
moved away but everyone
but but all these people they're not
just going to go back to being calm when
the next problem happens
it'll just keep on going forever um
so they really have really they've
really
uh they've really escalated this to a
point where
they've overplayed their hands because
they're just not enough of them to kill
all the people
yeah no strategy
yep
yeah well yeah well
that's the most exciting thing right now
in um
in this world that we're in right now is
uh
um is yeah is is
they've escalated they've re escalated
to a point where there there is going to
have to be fundamental change
people aren't going to accept others or
you know will it happen within a few
months
or in a few years who knows but it's
gonna happen
um and that's beautiful so thank you to
the portland police
thank you to ted wheeler thank you to
acting dhs secretary chadwolf thank you
to
belov my favorite president donald trump
like they've all
messed this up so much um
yeah so trump i think
trump is simultaneously given more
credit and less credit than he deserves
as a
strategist i think trump is an amazing
entertainer like for his he knows how to
read a room
like you watch a trump rally and it's
like
oh he's got the crowd in his hand and
yeah he oh my god can you imag hey
like booking trump that'd be great like
he'd bring a room yeah but
the him doing the water bit like where
he's like oh am i gonna do what am i
gonna do and it's like
people love that him imitating his
walking down the stairs
funny um like he's like a good
entertainer even though he's a horrible
horrible person yeah
he can be but he can be self-deprecating
yeah yeah
he he does and he's a great
tweeter he's his his posts are funny
he's it's gonna suck when we have like
president biden and he's just not going
to be posting anything nearly as
entertaining as trump
when like yeah well i mean and we don't
even know if
joe biden will be alive but um
no but uh so so i think that trump
did this partly because he was irritated
that this protest was happening and he
wanted to feel
tough um i and he but he also knew that
it would get him some support at
and he misses his big rallies because he
likes that
he he likes that more than being
president um he likes approval
so i think yeah i just don't i don't i
think it was
that was a strategy and i just don't
think it was the right strategy for what
he was really trying to do
because now he has to do more work which
is his least favorite thing of being
president seems is to do the president's
stuff
you know like
yeah i have no idea what he has to do
but he
you know he has to deal with this while
while coronavirus is
destroying america like he has to like
while there's an election happening that
he's gonna lose pro i mean maybe he
won't lose but he's gonna
i don't know um it's gonna be hard for
him to win
um like it's
it's and yeah yeah it's interesting that
he um
he's in a position that he has uh
totally and totally [ __ ] himself in
and uh and if he wins
you know what kudos donald kudos um
by i mean
45 of america is going to vote for him
no matter what like
it's just like that republicans people
vote or not 45
of america what like 10 you know the
portion of america that votes republican
it's you know
they're going to vote for him and then
of course
you guys look yeah
no no
no no one no one's having a good time
and like
so the way he could win of course is if
biden
dies like right before or has like a
stroke
right before the election but that also
could then make
people sympathy vote um so like
biden would have to like have a stroke
but not step down
or like it would be weird it would like
or and of course like it's gonna be a
hard election for people to take
seriously regardless because it's all
going to be like vote by mail and our
country is already so bad at that like
it's just going to be we're not going to
know the results of the election
for like a month and
so who knows like yeah it's oh november
is going to suck
um
[Music]
it yeah now you never i mean never
yeah yeah
what if bolsonaro somehow slides in and
wins the presidency of america
i would i would love that finally
finally a
person born outside of america and it's
this this fascist idiot who keeps on
getting coronavirus
um oh he's gotten it like four thousand
times
um it just seems like and doesn't he
i think i don't know i don't know how
many times it's been confirmed it may
have only been confirmed once but it
does seem like he's gotten it a bunch
and like he's disappeared a lot and
seemed sick a lot and then like his
all of his circle keeps on getting it so
it's like
it seems like he's gotten it multiple
times and i don't know if he hasn't but
i like the joke if he has
um yeah
oh no uh you know a lot of comedians are
out there
at the protests you know uh i mean
bentir
uh christian burke tiff maguire a lot of
those are out
you know document rachel miles
documenting the protest so that's it
there are some people that are insisting
on doing
comedy even though uh you know even
though they shouldn't
um do it live i don't support live
comedy right now because
you know there's been nothing that
stopped coronavirus
you know like except for i'm not gonna
bomb
i'm not gonna bomb and then kill people
you know like it's one of the other i
mean
maybe but still i still i don't like
that can i be right i'll be right back
right back
i'm back baby yeah living life um
yes so portland comedy what's portland
comedy like right now oh yeah so people
are doing outdoor
shows i look the problem with that
i think is that you know like every
comic deals with like
fomo and like career fomo with like damn
it if i'm not hustling grinding enough
like what is this all a waste i'm not
gonna get
like i'm not gonna break it big
i'm not gonna get booked at joker's
comedy club or whatever um
uh so whenever you see someone like
doing an outdoor
show you're like damn it i wish i was
doing more comedy
and then when a club is like hey we're
doing comedy stuff it immediately
makes you kind of think maybe i should
do that
like outdoor shows i think kind of
normalize doing
comedy in general right now
and i don't love it even though outdoor
stuff is safe
ish i just it stresses me out
given how quickly people just seem to
have stopped
caring about the fact that there's this
pandemic that hasn't been fixed it
hasn't been solved
uh
there are there are multiple ones also
like no offense to some of the people
that run them but they're being run by
people that i would not
call uh necessarily funny
you know like like there are some people
running good stuff but it's just like
it's just it's i don't think it's worth
it
um and you know there's like other
things you
can't be doing but organ oh yeah
[Music]
well that's yeah that's that's i mean
especially in new york new york is
like so hustle and grindy
yeah well yeah but they were like i mean
new york new york was still that state
in that city where like the epicenter so
it's like
i don't let me let me just even look at
the
the current stats for new york um
[Music]
it yeah
yeah but it has it you it is it has
plateaued a bit
but it's still an alarming rate where
it's like ever like
they've gone from having like 10 000
cases a day
in new york state to you know 700
which is like still which
we should remember that's still a lot
it's just not as
preposterous yeah well legacy the last
the last average the last day on july
28th
it was 715 in new york
so it's like it's it's it's
yeah i mean and and i mean
it's depressing to say but they had it
was such a big issue for
like a lot of people are gone because of
that uh oregon at the is like the
opposite
is where it's going up and up but we're
still not nowhere near new york
like our like highest number was uh i
believe
428 was our highest number of new cases
reported
in a day um
yeah there was a stat that i can't
remember it was like one out of every
400 new yorkers
in new york city had died from it like
i don't remember i i might be getting
this that horribly wrong
but it was something absurd like that
where like the amount of people who had
died in new york city
was just out was
yeah i mean i can i guess i can just
check right here um was
was a not small chunk of the population
i mean right now it's like what one out
of every
100 americans has had coronavirus
um i mean let me actually check that
first
so we've had what's called we've had a
total
in the united states 4.46 million
so uh cases so it's like like one out of
every 90 americans has had it i thought
i had it for a bit but then i was
just burnt out from the protests um
yes in new york is everybody to see new
york city
um i guess we can let's just assume all
of new york is new york city
just like a new yorker would um
yeah all right no there it is um
oh i can do it down here learning how to
do this is a very exciting podcasting
um but yeah so i don't know i think do
comedy online
all right so new york city yeah new york
city has had
uh 20 about 23
000 deaths from coven now let's see what
new york
city uh
population is so 23 000
new york city population um is
yeah so all right thank you for finding
that out i typed the wrong thing and
then i got distracted
all right
oh yeah you're right they do always say
that um well where's my count
where's my calculator app all right so
all right um let's see 2
23 000 divided by seven
million oh it's 8.3 million now but who
cares
come on oh yeah all right um
you know well yeah so eight mil all
right max
well yeah the point is i'm bad at this
ah
divided by
oh yeah oh that's not that much that's
not as much it's i guess
but it's like three percent of the
population
yeah so i'm great at math um
uh but uh yeah it's just it's it's yeah
so i mean a lot of people
who are vulnerable in new york have died
from it so
they have gotten yeah they have gotten
their treatment down but that's not at
what cost at a very horrible cost um
i think i don't know like i i never
loved
up as much as i love producing stuff so
it's been easier
for me to find the emotion i need
outside of life i mean of course i miss
the energy of a crowd i miss i miss that
i loved that
um but i don't you know it's great i
don't miss like the energy of no crowd
um yeah or just even hey i mean
you know you've done a show where you've
like produced it and worked hard
and like you booked like great good
names and then for some reason no one
and you've promoted it the hell and for
some reason like no one shows up
you know i mean at least i've been there
maybe you've never been there but i've
definitely been there
um and when that happens it's like
that sucks so i mean like i like doing
stuff on twitch now i do spec strip my
show on twitch
and like that feels like you don't get
the same energy of
the crowd but like you can see the
numbers
and when you have a bad number date it
doesn't feel nearly as bad as
like having to look at that in a crowd i
mean
with yeah the difference is when there's
when there's no crowd there in real life
you sometimes will have like 10 people
on stage for my show which is a table
read
you'll have 10 people on stage and you
look in the audience and there are two
people in the audience and it's like
well you never want to have more people
on stage than on the audience
um yeah and that sucks
yeah that's right i mean well the social
dynamic of comedy
can make it very toxic because it's a
great breeding ground for alcoholism
and for predatory behavior and all that
jazz um
that being said i mean i do feel i see a
lot of people slipping into despair
with quarantine life without having so
this is me doing a public service
announcement if you have any friends
at all reach out to them um and be like
hey do you want to watch a movie tonight
it's really fun to just have a phone
call with somebody
you're both having your headphones in
and you both watch a movie you press
play at the same time
and you both watch last night i watched
what i watched last night i watched
i watched the mask the jim carrey movie
um yeah yeah it's great and hey we all
wear masks now
um but then i watched the chord remember
the movie where they had to explode the
core to restart the core i watched that
a few days ago
it's fun
i wish i wish it's uh it's like it's
like what if armageddon but like not in
space it's under the surface of the
earth he has a wack
cast it's like aaron eckhart uh hilary
swank
del roy lindo stanley tucci uh alfred
woodard
richard jenkins uh dj qualls
you know it's it's fun it's a
yeah it really is it really is and tj
kwall
plays a hacker called the rat um
it's great um yeah stanley tucci has a
lot of hair in it
um so yeah like it's really fun to do
that like reach out to your friends this
is my psa
because it sucks like me like it's good
to be alone and remember who you are
um but also like we are a social
creature
so like check on people to make sure
that
the lack of direct human contact is um
is not driving them uh to despair
[Music]
[Music]
hmm it would suck if we didn't have this
right now like we didn't have the
ability to like interact
like because like i'll i'll just be
working on my garden all day
and like but i can talk to people on the
phone or i can text them and it feels
like i'm not alone
compared to like you know i mean if
if this happened back when you had the
like aol
sign in um like
like you're like oh god or like before
that can you imagine if we were just all
writing letters to me
or to me to each other but just like
writing
letters and then like you find out your
friend like
killed themselves because they were all
alone but you actually sent them a
letter but it took
too long to get like that would suck
that would be devastating like i'm glad
we have like
you can always check on somebody i can
check on someone right now um
i'll check yeah i'm gonna check on
someone at this very moment um
yeah just
yeah i'm calling a cop and saying hey
buddy your blue life matters
um a cab all cops are beautiful
uh yeah you put the fun in defund
um just
yeah we love this thing folks we love
yeah no um
uh it's um it's yeah it sucks
uh yeah i mean the time to suck but
social media as toxic as it can be
it does i mean i mean i'm grateful that
we have this
right now um i'm grateful
yeah yeah um well i gotta
quit my showtime edition i added to uh
hulu so i don't get charged for that
because i needed show time to watch
like the core um
yeah um
oh boy oh boy it really is um yeah no
so yeah yeah yeah have you been what
have you been doing how have you been
uh quarantining
ah dracula
[Music]
hmm that's awesome
oh i love oh i i i love me some weed i'm
gonna probably
light up some a pipe while i'm doing
some
i'm gonna weed while i weed my garden um
yeah uh
yeah exactly um
uh um yeah it's
it does yeah
um
[Music]
yeah that's fun
um yeah uh
i've been playing a little bit uh i've
not been gaming as much
as uh as as i thought
i was at the beginning before the
protest oh i was gaming
um but uh uh post
yeah um
uh yeah kind of it really
recontextualizes stuff i just bought uh
outer worlds um on my for like 20 bucks
and that's fun because it's kind of like
a fallout game but better
um and it's kind of anti-capitalist
you know it an anti-capitalist as like a
video game can be
but you know it's it's it's it's solid
and you get a smack
bandits with hammers i've yet to really
like get the groove of you know when
you're playing a video game and it takes
a while
to like get the rhythm of it to like it
i'm there with that right now where i'm
like i like it
yeah but i know i've not like gotten the
point where i'm like
you know like i can play i can play
skyrim whenever i want
you know even though skyrim arguably
sucks but i love skyrim
um oh
yeah yeah
and the fun the fun thing about skyrim
to make a commercial for a game that
came out ten years ago
um that everyone's is it's fun is that
skyrim
has a lot of like bad code problems in
it that break the game while you're
playing it
and make it impossible to play and
that's the real game is finding out the
ways to like
unbreak the game you know like i've i
i played to this point where i got to a
door that wouldn't open
this is very also exciting podcasting
but i got to a door that needed to open
for a mission
and it wouldn't open and i kept on like
looking online for how do i get through
this door i cannot continue the game
and i found out that if i ran at it with
a super speed
while holding a certain object if i hit
it just right i could phase
through the door and i spent like two
yeah and i spent like two days trying
that and i was on the phone with a
friend
the moment it happened and i was so
filled with an achievement and that was
the real game i don't care about like
killing an orc or whatever
i it's it's the part when the game is so
shadily made
that you like it ruins itself and you
have to find a way to fix it so that's
my advert
skyrim 2011. they never
fixed it yeah exactly
yeah exactly um
uh yeah but uh yeah so yeah oh
i
february maybe maybe february maybe
march
maybe it's a whole year um
oh there's a live truck uh i would not
say country good country is bad i like
that most country like all the other
countries have kind of handled it
apparently trump is doing um a uh press
conference
right now i want i bet he's saying that
he wants he's going to nuke
portland or something um
um yeah trump you need your safe space
um there's a person online who i i'm
not friends with that many trump people
but there's a woman online who is a
trump person she's sharing ben shapiro's
live stream of trump
and it's like wow that's a very cursed
sentiment um but yeah no
yeah we've handled this so badly because
any active uh work
to fix the crisis would uh
validate like
social democratic programs not even
liberals like because like it would
validate like the bernie sanders
movement you know
it would validate socialists you need to
pay for health care
you need to pay people you need to like
fix rent and
and housing and mortgaging you need to
like you need to
uh basically uh what's it called you
need to give people money to survive
like all the systems that are like
that are american they're like no we
can't do that this is america like
excuse me so this is america we cannot
have blah blah blah
like all that stuff is is you we can't
do communism no
oh dear moth every kind of communism
like you gotta eat like we're gonna
we're gonna in it admit it it admit it
and it's
well yeah i mean the the democratic
platform voted
overwhelmingly voted down including call
for medicare for all and it's like how
can you look at the corona virus crisis
and not be like
oh we need to have free health care in a
country that like
in a country where we're like no we
workers and employee-based healthcare is
good
it's like yeah but like
like who cares if it's good healthcare
if they lose it the moment the company
shuts down
the when there's a health crisis like
it's ridiculous it's so preposterous uh
and that's why we haven't done anything
and like now
all the companies are like we need to
reopen everything because we
need our money because we're not making
any money and it's like cool i'm glad
that we didn't do anything to actively
fix the problem
we just let a lot of people die and now
the disease is spiking in a lot of
places although apparently you know they
killed enough people in new york that
it's not spiking
there um and yeah it's a bummer uh
you know what that's that's yeah so who
knows
who knows um
oh yeah yeah oh and i just i just
looked back at the american stats just
again
like oh yeah we have like we spiked
early on we spiked in april and we
plateaued at that spike
and then we started spiking in june and
potentially are still spiking
or plateaued in july at a very alarming
high rate
um it's it's it's ridiculous like i
don't know how many
more people are gonna die before the
election but it's yeah we're gonna get
we're gonna get to 200 000 deaths
real soon um
[Music]
it still yeah it still wouldn't have
been good but yeah it would have
definitely been better um
it wouldn't have been good of course
because like part of the reason is like
the fear i have never mind i don't want
to get into too much about my thinking
of what if
clinton was president um
but uh because it didn't happen
um yeah but uh yeah
bleep times bleak times
[Music]
yeah yeah
new zeal yeah new zealand is yeah we
have like the least
uh transferable skill set of like
yeah linguistic based humor like
so new zealand is good england is okay
australia is fine
i don't know what south africa is like
yeah but moving to canada's hack
yeah yeah
um yeah yep
oh yeah so entering a 500 year decline
i love it yeah
[Music]
um i don't know um
i don't know i care enough about uh i
mean
look do i think uh look of course i love
xi jinping he's great we love him
um yeah we yes he's great
he's not like winnie the pooh at all uh
you know what what weakers um what hong
kong
like it's um i don't know it's it's
american culture is just so much more
expansionist
than other culture than other empires
that like look does
is china like slowly taking over africa
yeah
but like i don't know it's
i can't i don't know i don't really have
many i don't have any takes in china
um i get
yeah yeah
yeah um
no that's that's i mean that's
that's chinese capitalism for you you
know
like it's still it's it's it's you know
they say they're communist which is just
preposterous you know you don't take
over your people because your people
don't really matter it's only the people
in charge it's the same in every
every every nation every like there's
like
which is the anarchism yeah is
[Music]
yeah i mean it's
so my big takes is like regardless of
like
how a culture cares about its own people
uh you know capitalism makes it so that
you have to be evil to compete uh with
the evil um
so you know that's back to the
depressing stuff you know like
like i know because some people say yeah
yeah um yeah all right
vulcans come in bring us your culture um
yeah bring
mhm
[Music]
yeah yep
yeah well yeah
and people are a lot less greedy when
they're aware of their when they're
connected to their community
i think that's like it's just if you're
not connected to your community
like it's easier to [ __ ] over your
community
so that's yeah because everyone is
in it
it really yeah
yeah but we will we will sell out our
friends if it helps us um except for me
i'm the most loyal
um i am the only loyal comedian
um yeah yes yes
dab
anytime
will do yeah um i'm back out there
what's your podcast called never mind i
know what your podcast is called
um uh i did my research um
no uh i'm back out there in like a two
in in in august i'll be back in like mid
august they'll be back out in the
in the field trying to see what's
happening
um i hope i hope i'm not
uh i'm helping i hope i get out i'm
gonna be able to be out there for a
while
because um it's thanks they're
okay well thank you i'm glad because it
always feels weird when you do them
because
i listen to them back and like oh i
sound like a panicked exhausted dork
um because it's scary but uh it's also
i if you're if you're if you are
listening to this and you have a chance
to go out to a protest and it's not
gonna endanger
people in your life and it's not gonna
endanger itself too much
it's real it's a real thing to do it's
it's realer than any comedy thing it's
realer than any job you've ever had
you're actually fighting for
you're part of history so it's a cool
brave thing to do it's terrifying but
it's real
thank you thank you yeah a lot of good
people
here there's a gluttony of information
and i love that
all right it is
yeah thank you thank you
hmm yeah hey you guys got a
got a hockey team coming now
all right yeah all right
well yeah thank you so much for having
me thank you and i i that's what
will do and i'm gonna
yeah i'll slowly go party on buddy